The last piece that clicked was,
okay, there's something big here,
I love this industry.
There's an ability to really make
a difference for small businesses.
And then it was like, you know what,
this needs to be you doing it.
It can't be somebody else
executing on your vision.
You need to do it.
Eyal Liftshitz, thank you for joining me
all the way from California.
How are you?
I'm great.
Thanks for having me, Michael.
Of course. I'm both jealous
and not jealous of you.
I can't wait to come back
and live in Silicon Valley.
It's such a wonderful place.
But, you know, it's an interesting time
where we are now.
So, I'll hopefully we'll get
to meet in person in a few months.
But for now, I'll get to hear all about
your journey all the way from Israel
and Chicago Booth to Greylock,
McKinsey and now, BlueVine.
So, Eyal, first walk me back
all the way to your pizza delivery days.
What is that all about?
I think, well, I started by,
my first job was delivering pizzas, okay.
And I think this is
highlighting the fact that,
you know, I didn't start
my career in tech.
And even furthermore, you know,
kind of a funny or an anecdote here,
I did not own a computer
before I was around 22.
Really.
So, yes, I was a carefree teenager.
I served,
I didn't really care about technology.
In the military, I served in infantry.
I did not go to 8200 or 8100.
I basically, decided to go
and pursue a technology career
back in, it was 2000
when I started my degree
in electrical engineering.
And it was due to a choice that
I really didn't know
what I wanted to do in life at the time.
And high tech seemed
like a good opportunity.
You know, tech was booming
in the year 2000.
I didn't have a lot of sense
of what that means.
But you know what?
People are making good money
in technology,
why don't I go into high tech.
And the pizza delivery story
connect to that,
I think a little bit, even comically.
I used to deliver pizzas,
I lived in Ramat Aviv at the time,
and I delivered pizzas
in a pizzeria in Ramat Aviv.
And I used to deliver a lot to
like the tech companies
in Atidim and other places.
And I asked him, like,
"What are you guys doing?"
They were like,
"Well, we're engineers."
So, I was like, okay,
I need to go and do this job.
This is a good job, you know,
getting the pizza delivered to you
versus delivery.
So, that was the start of my you know,
my pizza delivery days is kind of like
grounded me into tech.
I love it.
Was it Pizza Fino by any chance?
It was Pizza Fino.
It is my all time favorite pizza.
I'm from Ramat Aviv as well,
and I used to eat there
almost on a daily basis.
So, we already have
a huge thing in common.
And I'm hugely appreciative
even more than what you do at BlueVine,
I think what you did with Pizza Fino
tops that much more so.
So, thank you for that.
But you're actually,
your entrepreneurial experience
goes beyond just the pizzas
and then your understanding to transition
to a different industry.
Your family, you say
you're a third generation
entrepreneur. Right?
So, talk to me a little bit about that
and how that runs in the family.
It's an interesting story here.
And I don't know
if it runs in the family.
And I'll explain further on that.
My dad was a small business owner.
He had a physical therapy clinic
in the Upper East Side
of New York for 30 years.
His dad owned a
kind of lighting electricity lighting
store in Dizingof for 40 years.
So, both of them were
small business owners.
And you know,
the reason why small
business owners start their business is
many of them don't want a boss.
And they want to be able to run, you know,
their own kind of thing and do their own,
you know, run their own show.
And so, I view small business owners
as entrepreneurs by their own right.
They start their company,
or their business or their whatever.
And they share
many of the same things
that we do in startup land
when we start a company.
There's many of the same pain points,
you need to figure out
your business plan,
your hiring, how to generate revenue.
Of course, it's a different outcome.
And they're not looking to build
a billion dollar companies.
But there's a lot of the same stuff,
especially when they start out.
Right.
You know, in terms of running
in the family, I don't know
if it runs in the family.
I didn't know that I wanted to be
an entrepreneur
up until I started BlueVine.
If you look at my career, you know,
it's a pretty safe journey.
I kind of stuck to larger companies,
pretty strong brand names.
I didn't really take any risk
before I started BlueVine.
There are some people that
they graduate from college and they know
that their destiny is to start a company.
They know they want to be
an entrepreneur.
I did not have that.
Interesting.
I wasn't that.
I very much followed a safe path.
And the reason I started BlueVine
was less so about the personal interest
or the draw to actually become a founder,
but rather
the opportunity and the calling.
You know, even further adding to that
in the beginning,
the mindset working in venture capital
and seeing the opportunity
to start BlueVine I was like,
why don't we find a CEO to do this.
When do we found
somebody else to do this.
I wasn't thinking that this would be me.
But I got so consumed with the idea
and the opportunity that at some point,
you know, this is mine,
I need to really go do this.
So, walk me through
that thinking process.
Because you're a principal at Greylock,
one of the best investment groups
in the world based in your,
in the cohort based in Israel.
You're thinking about this industry.
You're thinking about
small business owners.
Obviously, this has a connection to you
coming from a family
of small business owners
and you're understanding
that there is a gap in the market,
an opportunity that at the end you decide
to go and fulfill it
yourself with BlueVine.
What are those weeks, days, months like?
What does that process look like
for a safe journeyed
you know, technology guy and
somebody who is working in tech,
working in fantastic beginnings,
McKinsey, Greylock.
And you're saying, you know what,
I'm ready to go start my own journey.
What is that thinking
process like for you?
It was an evolution.
So first, when you work in venture,
you get exposed
to entrepreneurship in general.
You worked with a lot of founders.
You assess investments.
And, you know, entrepreneurship
is somewhat infectious.
You see the excitement of people
starting something from nothing.
You kind of follow their journey
from the outside in.
And, you know,
there's a lot of excitement
that rubs off.
So first, being in venture
did move me closer in that direction.
The story of BlueVine at the beginning
was more of an analytical exercise.
I had an opportunity to look
and see a lot of companies
in the fintech space
through Greylock Israel.
And there were heavy investors
in fintech at the time.
And I realized
that there's an opportunity,
there's a white space,
specifically at the time when we started
the company and factoring.
And I was a big fan
of what was happening
in online financing,
and I realized there were
still areas of opportunities.
And so, when I learned
about factoring at the time,
it clicked that there is an ability
to take a page from what was being done
in other sort of products
and apply it here.
And the market sizes is quite large.
And so that from an analytical
from the outside in, it really connected.
And then there was
a personal passion always to
evaluate and see opportunities
within small businesses.
And this does relate
to my personal background.
I did grow up
around my father's business.
I heard about him talking about
growing up with his father's business,
around his father's business.
It's something that was always around me.
I had a connection to this segment.
And so those two things came together
in terms of,
wow, there is really something here.
And the last piece that clicked was,
okay, there's something big here.
I love this industry.
There's an ability to really make
a difference for small businesses.
And then it was like, you know what,
this needs to be you doing it.
It can't be somebody else
executing on your vision.
You need to do it.
And, you know,
while I was 35 at the time,
I did not want to be an entrepreneur
until that point in my life.
At that point, sort of like the regret
minimization framework kicked in.
It was like, if I don't do this,
I'm going to regret it
20 years in the future.
So, I jumped in.
So, do you categorize yourself
as a full time entrepreneur?
I categorize myself
as a full time founder.
Yes, a full time entrepreneur.
You know, I think
when you start a company, the definition
of entrepreneur versus CEO,
they get kind of
mixed over the life of a company.
Right.
I think I'm becoming more and more
of a CEO as time goes by
and the company becomes larger.
Of course, I'm a founder CEO.
So, that is something that is
always part of my sort of outlook.
But as time goes by,
as you take more of the role of the CEO
and your role in the company rather
than just being the founder.
Sure. Can you share a little bit more about
about the industry
and the market of small businesses?
What's happening today,
especially in the United States
that you're observing?
How do you even get to that
that big pain point that you've observed?
And what is the trend look like
as we are now in 2021, I guess?
So, I will say that the vision
of the company evolved significantly
from when we started.
We started with a very narrow
product set,
answering, factoring
and making that an online product
then evolved to providing a full range
of printed products.
And today, we really involved
in delivering end to end banking.
And so, it wasn't,
there wasn't any pivot along the way.
This was a continued expansion
of the business model and strategy.
So, you're considering it
as an evolvement,
as an evolvement of that narrow idea
that you've understood, okay,
there's actually a bigger gap
than what we thought.
Yes.
You know, there was an entry point here,
but over time, realizing that
the real opportunity is to essentially
fix small business banking as a whole
and factoring is part of credit
and credit is part of banking.
And banking as a whole,
is broken for small businesses.
And that is the true opportunity
that we're looking to solve,
which includes everything that belongs
under making checking accounts,
credit, payments, everything else.
This has been sort of an evolution
that happened through
understanding our customers
and their pain points.
Now, when you
are referring to small businesses,
broadly, what has been happening
in the last two decades, essentially,
they've been outsourcing
their financial services from their bank
no longer that they do most of their
or interact with their bank for most
of their financial services need.
They still hold their checking account
with their bank.
But payment processing
they get from Square,
from PayPal, from Stripe.
Payments, they get from bill.com.
Credit, they get historically
from third party lenders
like us and others.
It's been a world where
things that you would expect to get
from your bank and corporations
definitely get from their bank.
Small businesses end up needing to rely
on many third party providers,
not their bank.
And that is not an ideal market.
That's not an ideal outcome.
The ideal outcome is
they can actually have a banking partner
that can answer all of their needs
under one place
and everything works together seamlessly.
And that is what we're doing.
Providing them access
to everything they need under one roof
and making it very easy
to transact digitally.
That's another big point.
And that really connects to the pandemic.
It's interesting. Both consumers,
they don't go to the branch anymore.
When's the last time
do you went to the branch?
I sometimes ask that question
and people tell you,
I actually went last week.
Eyal, I don't even know
that there are branches
that are still existing.
You're telling me a new news now.
I can't believe that
they're still operating in person.
They are.
And you know, when you look at the
small business segment, interestingly,
while consumers over time
have stopped going to the branches,
definitely the younger generations,
small businesses, small business owners
on average still go, on average,
at least once a week to the branch.
Why?
Because they don't have everything
at their disposal
to be able to transact digitally.
You know, adding to that the pandemic,
that doesn't work anymore.
So, certainly there's a lot of like
tailwinds right now for providers like us
to be able to provide a small business
the ability to transact digitally
without needing to go to the branch.
Certainly right now is not a time where
small business value going to the branch.
And even before it was a hassle
and the time stuck.
Now, it's just impossible
and there's a health concern.
So, that certainly is giving us
an increased push for what we're doing.
In addition,
during this time when small businesses
have been struggling
and facing a lot of challenges
given the economic environment,
the banking industry has not necessarily
all stepped up to serving them,
you know, in a very robust way.
And so, the fact that we are 100%
focused on this segment
and are able to deliver really
great banking experience, I think
today even speaks even more loan.
And I think that one of the most
fascinating things that I love
about what you're doing is that
it's not just that you're coming in
and you're educating the market,
but you have a series of other players
that are coming in,
they're educating the market
on the different angles. Right.
So, obviously, the digital transactions
and the whole way that we're dealing
with digital assets today
are completely different
than 10, 15 years ago.
And having that
end to end banking solutions,
I'm looking at the different
banks here in Israel
and in the United States,
the adaptation is so slow.
They're still focused on
the different consuming habits.
And I think that what you're doing here
has impeccable timing.
And obviously, I can't imagine
in pandemic of 2020,
the different you know,
the way that you seeing your vision
coming together and how
the world has accelerated
towards this new world
that you're providing a solution to.
But Eyal, I also want to pick your brain
as the founder and CEO.
So, you're saying that you're
transitioning solely from being
the founder and the entrepreneur
towards now being the CEO?
You're the CEO of a company
that raised hundreds
of millions of dollars, right?
It's a big responsibility.
Lots of employees.
Now, you really are a big CEO
of considerably big company.
What are some of the thoughts shifts
that you've had to do as a leader
intrinsically, as you're transitioning
to your role?
Because your role today,
I am imagining is very, very different
from your role four or five years ago.
Right?
And it's been a very quick shift.
Yeah. I mean,
quick is a relative term, right?
It's been seven years
since we started the company.
And it feels like,
it's like startup years
are like gotten years, you know.
On one hand,
it feels it was just only yesterday
that we started the company.
But when I'm reflecting back
and everything that we went through over
over seven years, it's a lot.
It feels like a lifetime.
Yes, the transition is significant
from starting out to over time,
it doesn't happen in one day.
In the beginning, a founder,
you do everything that you need to do.
You're basically the, you know, the cook,
the you know, the office manager,
the recruiter, the programmer.
You do whatever you need to do
in the beginning,
you're all up the sleeves
and you work towards getting stuff done.
And, you know, in the beginning,
there's a lot of focus on you doing.
And of course, you hire employees,
but you are involved
in whatever needs to be done.
And there's a lot of things to be done
and shortage of resources.
And you make all of the decisions
in the beginning, a lot of the decisions
flow through you.
Over time, it becomes less of doing,
but more of making sure
that you have the right people in place
and you're empowering them
and you're creating the right
organizational structures
to be able to scale.
So, it's interesting, you know.
The type of work that you do
as the founder
really changes every two years
based on the size of the company
and based on kind of the
general scale of the business.
So, you know, it's not one day,
but it does, every two-year,
you kind of need to think about
what do I need to be doing,
what do I not need to be doing.
The things that you always own
as a CEO is the vision.
You always are responsible
for selling the company.
In selling I mean,
to investors, to employees, to media.
You're always on a sales mode.
You always drive culture.
That happens from the early days,
even when the company is larger,
that is a responsibility of the CEO.
And, you know, and again, vision.
Like vision and strategy
is sort of like connected.
And there are different types of CEOs.
There are sort of like
more product oriented CEOs
and there's more sales oriented CEOs.
I personally,
I put myself more in the first category.
And so, I'm very passionate
about product.
And I do get involved in product.
Even my level of involvement with product
has changed considerably over time.
In the beginning,
I was literally writing specs myself
and working with the engineers over time.
As we grew, we have product management.
Now we have a phenomenal
chief product officer.
Now, it's more about just
providing feedback around the roadmap,
making sure that
the vision is instilled
with the, you know,
the plan that we're putting together.
And then obviously, I have opinions around
certain product and specifically around
product experience that I
make sure to voice them.
But I am no longer in the driver's seat.
I'm more of a coach
of a reactive sort of position.
When you're building a company.
The main thing you want to do is
to make sure that you have
really great people that are motivated
and are pushing forward.
Because as you scale,
you can't be everywhere.
So, it becomes from you doing everything
to make sure that
you have phenomenal people
that are able to execute on your vision.
So, it sounds to me
like your journey is full of firsts.
Right?
Every two years, your role is changing.
But that means that really
every two years
you are reinventing your role as the CEO.
You have to adapt
to the new environment
every time you get a chance
to debrief over what you've learned
and sort of the skills you've mastered,
you all of a sudden have to reinvent
and master these new skills.
So, how do you keep yourself in check?
Because it sounds to me like a lot
of the things that you have to deal with
every now and then are brand new.
And maybe sometimes there are things
that you don't have
the right skill sets to do.
How do you, as the CEO,
the person that everybody is looking
towards, how do you keep
yourself balanced and making sure that
you're actually doing the right thing?
I think the way to do that is learn
from everybody around you,
learn from your investors and your board.
Learn from your executive team.
It's interesting.
As the founder or CEO of a company,
you get to be the only
executive on the team
without experience and learning. Right.
It's an interesting phenomenon like,
if we're talking scales,
you end up having very
senior executives around you,
which you are much less experienced
than them.
And that's okay
because you bring something different
to the table.
But you need to be
open and vulnerable
and you need to be able
to be in a position when you're learning
from people around you
and you're accepting feedback.
And so some of the changes
and an evolution for me,
again, this is my first time as a CEO,
I wasn't a CEO before,
so it is learning through feedback.
It is this being
in a position where
you have your ears open
and you're hearing what people
are saying and sometimes
it's painful feedback.
It's people telling you
you shouldn't be doing this,
you should be doing this.
And, you know, you could be in a position
and be defensive
and clutch on to
your previous behaviors,
but then you would not grow.
So, I think part of my ability to grow
as a CEO in this company is just,
you know, being open to feedback,
reflecting on it and thinking about
how I can get better every day.
And that is something that I do.
Every week, I think to myself,
what should I be doing
and what shouldn't I be doing.
I love that.
Eyal, thank you so much
for being so generous with your time.
I know how busy you are.
And you have so much on your plate,
and I really appreciate you
taking the time to provide your insights,
expertise and your humble nature.
Honestly, it really does inspire me
to watch a CEO as a learner.
And I hope to take a similar route
to yours and continue to be
a lifelong learner and keep checking
who are the right people around me
and what do I need to do
to continue learning and adapting.
Before we leave,
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Three words.
Honest.
Hardworking.
And funny.
I try to take things lightly.
I love that.
Eyal, toda raba
Thank you very, very much.
And best of luck with BlueVine.
And I hope to meet you in person
after this whole thing spins out,
this pandemic.
Thank you.
Same here. Take care.